حنتكلم اليوم على بلد حسب برنامج جوده
الحياه نسبه التنقل العام صفر في المئه
واحد واحد ما شاء الله زين واحد في الميه
فقط رغم ان احنا نتكلم على اربعين سنه 42
سنه استثمار في هذا القطاع بس خلينا يعني
نحكي في اليوم
في عقد للمترو الرياض يشمل حافلات حدثنا
على الجزء اللي انتم مسؤولين عنه اللي هو
موضوع الحافلات نقل بالحافلات وليش 15 شهر
واحنا نشوف الباصات تدور فاضيه ما احنا
عارفين ايش قاعده تسوي
ممتاز
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه ونعم في استضيف
قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال وقاده الراي
وسولف معهم مع المستجدات ومستهدفات رؤيه
السعوديه 2030 ضيف حلقه اليوم هو المهندس
خالد الحقيل الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه
السعوديه للنقل الجماعي ثابتكم يمكن
اصدقائي الرهيبين في السناب شات يعرفون
انه ما في قضيه اكثر من قضيه النقل العام
شاغله للفتره الماضيه وزحمه الرياض
وتحديدا سؤال وش قصه هالباصات اللي تدور
في مدينه الرياض وهي فاضيه
فاخيرا لقينا احد يقدر يجاوب على هذا
السؤال شركه سابتكو هي المشغل
لحافلات مترو الرياض فهذا كان جزء مهم من
حوارنا احنا بدينا الحوار بتعريف بالشركه
اكثر من 45 سنه من لحظه البدايه واشكال
الهدف ايش المراحل اللي مرت فيها الشركه
متى اوقف الدعم متى استقلت كيف عوضت الدعم
الحكومي بمصادر دخل اخرى وش قطاعاتها وايش
مجالاتها والشركات اللي تحتها بعدين دخلنا
على الموضوع
الرياض زحمه الرياض وش حيصير فيه طبعا هم
مش مسؤولين عن المترو فما حكينا عن المترو
لكن حكينا عن الحافلات لانه هم المشغل
لهذه الحافلات مش مواصفاتها ايش تغطي ايش
مستوياتها الاربعه متى حتبدا ليش طولت
فتره التشغيل التجريبي اللي ما كان فيها
استخدام من عموم المجتمع اتكلمنا ايضا على
العقود الجديده للتنقل بين المدن السعوديه
قسمت الى ثلاث مناطق وكل منطقه تولاها
تحالف مسؤول عن التنقل بالحافلات بين هذه
المدن فاتحدثنا عن هذا المشروع تحدثنا عن
النقل داخل مدن تحدثنا عن قصص ما نجحوا
فيها مثل تكسي المطار اللي كانت قصه فشلت
تكلمنا عن مشاكل
التوطين في هذا القطاع بحكم انه يغلب عليه
بشكل كبير السائقين وختمنا كالعاده
بمجموعه من اسئلتكم الثمينه مثل تجربه
المستخدم في التطبيق وصعوبه الحجوزات
الاونلاين موقع محطه التنقل لجنوب الرياض
قاعده تصعب المهمه على سكان شمال الرياض
والى اخر اسئلتكم الثمينه اترككم مع
الحوار حياك الله ابو فيصل شرفت ونورتنا
الله يحييك ويسعدك سعيد جدا باستضافه
واتمنى ان شاء الله يعني نطلع بحلقه مفيده
وثريه في احد محاور الحياه محاور صناعه
النخل قبل النقل ابو فيصل ودي اسالك كم
فرق العمر بينك وبين الوالده الله يرحمها
[ضحك]
الوالده يعني كان تزوجت وهي صغيره جدا
عمرها 15 سنه وبالتالي بيني وبينها 16 سنه
16 سنه 16 سنه فقط ونكاد نكون يمكن عشنا
حياتنا مع بعض الله يرحمها اغرب ما نكون
الى يعني صديق وصديقته اخ واخته ابن مع
امه فكان يجمعنا الكثير الكثير بشكل يعني
كانت سبحان الله كانك هزيتني الان لانها
كانت على مفارقه ومؤثره في حياتي لا شك
وكيف يفرق هذا في مثلا الفرق بين علاقاتها
بك وعلاقتها ببقيه اخوانك
والله يعني
الابن اقرب لامه فما بالك والعمر قريب جدا
فكيف اثر هذا يعني كما يقال اذا كانت كل
فتاه بابيها معجبه
بالنسبه لي في علاقتي مع الوادي العده
اعتبارات انا اكبر اخواني هي كانت اكبر
اخوانها هي يعني عاشت يتيمه الام في فتره
مبكره وبالتالي كانت تحس بالمسؤوليه وهذا
كان دائما يعني بالنسبه لي ملفت للنظر اني
انا ارى دوري في دورها مع حياه فيك تولي
مسؤوليه طبعا ايضا زد عليه انها يعني عاشت
غير انها يتيمه وتحمل سريه اخوانها لما
تزوجت ايضا صغيره كانت كانت ايضا تجربه
صعبه عليه انها كانت غريبه بحكم مع
الوالده الله يرحمه كنا عشنا غرباء من يوم
تقريبا ولدت في الجزائر بعدين درست بدايه
الابتدائي في لبنان الى انهينا ابتدائي في
امريكا
فتخيل امراه وصل عمرها يمكن العشرينات مع
سبعه يعني ابناء وتعيش في غربه مستمره كان
بالنسبه لي الحقيقه دائما مسافه تامل وخلق
مواقف كثيره جدا بيني وبينه في حياتنا
وانا اعتقد انها كانت مجموعه مدارس مدارس
في الاخلاق مدارس في التضحيه مدارس في
الصبر مدارس في
لمه الاسره واقتبست منها وكنت اتعلم منها
حتى يا اخي المفاوضات لما تروح تشتري لو
تروح معها لما نروح في مناسباتنا لما لما
يعني كانت حتى تعتمد عليه اقرب ما اكون
اليها انا ابنها انا بنتها اساعدها في
البيت
في
الترتيب البيت في
المناسبات في العزائم فكان الله يرحمها
يعني لها تاثير علي وعلى اخواني بشكل كبير
لكن كنت دائما اعتز بمحبته وقربها الكثير
جدا يؤثر علي حقيقه فيمكن مسار حياتي كله
في جوانب كثيره فالله يرحمها الله يغفر له
ويرحمه يعني شخصيه رائعه
اسميها انا مجموعه مدارس اسمها مدرسه او
جامعه عزيزه عز الله
ويمكن احنا اليوم سعداء ابو فيصل ان انا
نكسبك بصفتك تقود واحده من اهم الشركات في
قطاع جدا مهم وحيوي اللي هي شركه النقل
الجماعي انت تقود 2006 على ما اظن فيعني
عصرت نصف عمر هذا الشركه تقريبا
وفيه يعني اسئله كثيره واسئله بعضها حيكون
يعني ثقيل دم عليك لكن تحملنا بس لان
الموضوع مره مثير بس قبل ما نطب في العميق
ونسالك عن متر الرياض نسالك على خلينا
نبدا ونعرف عن هالشركه وش فكرتها وش
تاريخها وايش كان غرض من تاسيسها طبعا
اي بلد في تحضره لما تروح تسافر حتى تجد
اول واجهه لك عما يتخلف او تقدم هذا البلد
جزء منه المطار
تعامل الجوازات خروجك الى استخدام وسائل
النقل فلا شك ان الدوله يعني بدات في عام
1979 بعد ما بدات خطوط السعوديه 1945
القطار 1951 كان لابد من ربطها المدن
والقرى في قاره مثل المملكه مليونين كيلو
متر مربع لابد من ربطها بشبكه نقل اللي هي
الحافلات لما تاسست الشركه عام 1979 تاسست
براس مال 30% من الحكومه وسبعين بالمئه
للقطاع الخاص وش الهدف الهدف انهم يشركون
ويرغبون الناس في وسائل النقل بان يكون هم
الملاك عن طريق المساهمه ويكونون هم
المستخدمين والحقيقه يعني كانت
[موسيقى]
المدن طبعا كان اول شيء في البدايه النقل
داخل البلدان ثم النقل بين المدن فلكن
تخيل تضبط اكثر من 300 مدينه وقريه وهجره
عبر شبكه النقل هذه داخل المدن ايضا كانت
فيك الايام فتره اللي هي المشاريع الضخمه
في بدايه خلينا نقول منتصف السبعينات
وبدايه الثمانينات اللي كان فيها العماله
بشكل كبير وتنقل في هالجزيره
الهيئه الملكيه بالضبط كل مشاريع هذيك
كانت تقام وكانت ذيك الايام الحركه النقل
بشكل كبير فكان لابد من سد هذا الفراغ عن
طريق توفير شبكه النقل
طبعا استمرت الشركه على ماده خل نقول
عشرين سنه لانه اصلا شبكات النقل عندما
تبنى على مستوى العالم كله هي لازم تكون
مدعومه
فانت اليوم عندك مساهمين يمثلون قطاع خاص
عندك الحكومه مساهم الاكبر نسبه 15%
وعليك انك تؤدي واجبات وفي نفس الوقت حقق
ارباح وهذا اصعب شيء
فكانت الدوله في
التزامها او في عقد الالتزام مع الشركه
انها تضمن تغطيه كل تكاليف الخساره لتشغيل
هذه الشبكه وتضمن ربح قدر 15% في البدايه
ثم صار عشره ثم صار سبعه اذا توقف الدعم
بعد عشرين سنه في عام 1998
ليش توقف الدعم في ذاك الوقت طبعا طلع
قرار اللي هو ايقاف الدعم عن الذكر شركه
الاستراحات على الطرق ساسكو شركه النقل
الجماعي سابتكو اتذكر انديه الادبيه شركه
الغاز الخلفيه ولكن
جانب الثاني طبعا انه ما كان الاقبال من
المواطنين في ذاك الوقت نتيجه انه احنا في
بلد صعب جدا مقومات النقل العام صعب من
حيث ايش من حيث رخص الوقود
الطرق مجانيه المواقف مجانيه الطرق
والسيعه ما في ضرائب على السيارات تذاك
الوقت فبالتالي من اللي ما يبغى ان يكون
يحصل على خصوصيته بين ينتقل سيارته
ويقضي حاجاته طبعا تراكمت هذه الامور اللي
صارت الشركه في وضع صعب عن ثمان سنين بعد
ايقاف الاعانه وهذا فكره هذا احيانا بعض
الناس يرمي الى انه قد يكون سوي اداره
ابدا في مفاهيم النقل العام في كل دول
العالم من خلال مرجعيه اتحاد العالمي
للنقل
كل شبكه نقل عام بحكمنا مظهر حضاري
واقتصادي يجب ان يتم تمويله وتغطيه العجز
في كم يوصل العجز من 60 الى يمكن خمسه
وثمانين بالمئه تتخيل بشكل مذهل طبعا في
عام 98 ان كان لابد على سابتكو انها يعني
تراجع نفسها في ايقاف الاعانه وصح ما زال
باقي معها الامتياز لكن بدات تركز هنا على
النقل بين المدن حكم هو النشاط المربح
داخل مدن ما هو مربح وناخذ المدن هو غير
مربح على الاطلاق فعلى سبيل المثال
في امريكا تغطيه التذاكر لتكلفه النقل
العام ما تصل الى 35 بالمئه
والباقي الباقي يروح يغطى من دافع الضرائب
من دعم الحكومه لانها خدمه حضاريه
واقتصاديه لما تروح لاوروبا اللي تشوف
الكثافه العاليه فيها في وسائل النقد
المترو مليان الباصات مليانه ترى ما يغطي
40 الى خمسه وخمسين بالمئه
باريس على سبيل المثال ما يغطي اكثر من
35%
لكن لما تروح من اوروبا لخمسه كمعدل عام
تروح شرقا الى جنوب شرق اسيا حيث المدن
الرئيسيه وكثافه السكانيه هناك نصل الى
معدلات 85%
بالنادر بالنادر انك تغطي التكلفه هي
المدن الرئيسيه الثلاثه
اللي تعتمد تماما على على نسبه نقل العام
يصل الى 80 الى من ثمانين الى 95% فما
بالك عندنا في السعوديه نسبه تغطيه او
نسبه المشاركه النقل العام اتمثل لواحد
بالمئه حسب الرؤيه النصل الى 15 ضعف يتحقق
في عشرين ثلاثين واحد مكونات او مسرعات
اننا نصل الى هذه النسبه هو طبعا لا شك
مشروع ما يكبر العزيز في العاصمه الرياض
على اساس ان يكون احد مقومات جوده الحياه
اللي يطمح لها ان شاء الله عشان الخص اللي
فاتوا
الناقل الحصري بين المدن وداخل المدن
الناقل العام انتوا اخذتوا حقوق حصريه
بالضبط قعدتو عشرين سنه مدعومين 98 وقف
الدعم فقلصته نشاطكم صرتوا تشتغلون فقط
خارج بين المدن وخارج ومنها وجت فكره
النقل المميز اللي هو الفي اي بي والنقل
الدولي صرت انت برضه تسوون رحلات دوليه
وفي النقل المتخصص اللي هو حجاج تعليم الى
اخره بعد مرحله
اعاده التموضع بالضبط طيب اليوم يعني بعد
هذا التموضع انتو لسه ربحانين ولا مدعومين
ولا
الحنا من عام 98 لما توقفت الاعانه استمري
الحمد على الصعوبه اللي احنا فيها
نحقق ارباح الين جت
قضيه اللي هو في 2019 18 و19 كان اعاده
هيكله جديده للشركه والتوسع والتوجه للنقل
للتنقل الرقمي
التوسع في المشاريع الملياريه في مشاريع
المدن الجديده
فوقفنا اول سنتين لاول مره في تاريخنا لا
نصرف ارباح بسبه ولكن نحقق ارباح لكن لا
نصرف توزيعات في 20 21 22 كانت الضربه
القاسيه الحقيقه لكل من يشتغل في قطاع
النقل والسياحه
بشكل يعني انا اعتقد في كيانات غابت ولا
الحمد موقف الشركه الماليه القوي نتيجه
الاحتياطيات لبناها نتيجه الارباح
الى 18 تربحون نعم وتوزعون بدون دعم حكومي
صفر دعم حكومي تماما
وجت كوفيد واثرت عليكم لانه بطبيعه الحال
انتم مربوطين بالحركه والتنقل وهذي لا سفر
ولا تنقل داخلي
وش سويتوا بعدها عشان بس نكمل القصه طبعا
لما يكون قضينا المرحله الاولى كان عندك
دعم وعندك امتياز خلصنا منها بعد 20 سنه
المرحله الثانيه كانت عندك امتياز بس ما
عندك دعم فكان عباره عن اعاده بناء الشركه
والتهيئتها لما بعد انتهاء الامتياز اللي
كان مرور 30 سنه 15 الاولى ثم التجريده 15
ثانيه في 2008 كانت هي المرحله الثالثه
اللي كان لابد على الشركه ان تجد خطاها
وطريقها كيف تكون فيما بعد الامتياز
فجينا وسوينا الحقيقه مع احد السوريين
العالميين مراجعه لكل شيء مش ممكن ننسى وش
ممكن نسويه اولا اننا ننتقل من نطاق او
نمط نمط من انماط النقل اللي هو فقط النقل
بالحافلات الى الانفتاح على الاخرين ان
ليش ما ننقل بالليمون ايش معنى ينقلب
بالمتروليش ما نروح في قضيه القياده
الذاتيه النقل التشاركي فاصبحنا يجب ان
ننتهج
اننا يبدا نطور الشركه عبر يمكن العديد من
وحده منهم اول شيء اعاده تغيير خلنا نقول
كلتشره او
[موسيقى]
شركه وثقافه الشركه من الصعب اخوي عمر انه
لما يكون موظفينه بالشركه عاشه وكل 30 سنه
على انه دعم وبالتالي عليهم بس يؤدون
اعمالهم
بعيد عن قضيه التسويق عن تجويد عن طريق
الميكنه عن طريق تجديد الاسطول عن طريق
تغيير الاصول عن طريق اظهارك بهويه ثانيه
مختلفه تبع تبحث فيها عن المشاريع التي
سوف تاتي المملكه حتما اما اتكلم عن 2008
وامتياز كان قارب على انه بينتهي نعرف
تماما ان الدون السعوديه ويتموا وتكبر
الزحام هذا سوف ياتي يوم من الايام يجيب
معه مشاريع كبيره مشاريع بانماط مختلفه
حتكون مكونه من مترو على حافلات على
السيارات حسب الطلب عشان تشكل انماط النقل
وتسوي منظومه النقل اذا وش نسوي نجاه لا
بدينا في البحث عن الشركات العالميه مع
كبر الشركات اللي متخصصه في مجالات مختلفه
وهذا كان الحمد لله مفتاح الانطلاق
والاستعداد بدليل لما جاء عام 2012 وطرح
مشروع الملك عبد العزيز اللي يعتبر مشروع
الاكبر على مستوى العالم من حيث مشروع ضخم
مرحله لعاصمه ضخمه
في كثافه 8 مليون وقتها لمساحه الفين كيلو
متر مربع من الصفر من العدم نقل العام فقط
تريد ان تبني في شبكه متكامله في فتره عشر
سنوات
اللي بني في اليوم او يبنى في الرياض
اليوم هو يعادل ما بني في 150 سنه في
باريس او 150 سنه في لندن فتخيل هذا
التحدي الكبير كنا جاهزين ولله الحمد مكنا
اعمالنا رتبنا استقطبنا عقول من شركات على
اساس ننشئ ثقافه جديده فيها الحس المالي
فيها الحس التسويقي فيها الحس المعرفي
الحس التقني وهذا جعلنا ولا الحمد دخلنا
في اكبر منافسه يمكن على هذا المشروع
الضخم خلينا نقول من شرقه من طوكيو الى
كولومبيا غربل 143 شركه جت
عبر تحالفات كنا احنا مع تحالف الفرنسيين
ار تي بي والله الحمد صرنا من ضمن
التحالفات السته التي استطاعت ان تاهل
منها
فقط اللي قدموا عروضهم ودراساتهم بالاخير
فزنا بما يعني كنا مستعدين للحفاظ على
مكانتنا واستمرارنا كعلقه خل نقول هذا
المولود لولدته الحكومه انه ما يروح عبث
وان يكون تفضيل لانكم انتم شركه محليه
ابدا يعني ما اعطوكم ما في احد عرض افضل
منكم بس انتم تفوته في المحتوى المحلي او
احنا كنا الافضل ماليا فنيا وبالتالي ولله
الحمد كنا عددنا العده بما يتناسب مع هذا
خلينا نقول الاختبار العظيم في ان تذهب
الشركه سدى لو ضاعت وفقدت او انها تبدا
مرحله جديده متطوره تعبر اننا ذكرنا الدرس
جيدا عديناه للعده جبنا افضل المشغلين
وسوينا افضل تحالف وهذا اليوم ان شاء الله
على وجهك نخطف الثمار
بالشركه اللي هي اليوم وش الشركات يعني هل
هي شركه قابضه تحتها شركات ولا هي شركه
وحده تقدم كل هذا الخدمات لما جينا في
هيكله الشركه بعد المرحله 2008 2018 كانت
البحث عن العالميه بدنا نبحث عن الشركات
لنكون شركات انكم مستعدين للمناقصات
الضخمه ونكون ان شاء الله يعني جاهزين
للتنافس على اساس اننا
يجب ان نحصل على اكبر حصه من هذه المشاريع
الضخمه
2018 يعني ذكرتها فيما سبق كانت نقطه تحول
يجب اننا الان نحط استراتيجيه جديده
اللي هي بشكل
يتفاعل مع خل نقول التطور الرقمي الهائل
في حياتنا اليوميه
سبحان الله لما حطيناه كان كانت عباره عن
اننا ننتقل الى مجموعه جروب تحت مجموعه
شركات حوالي سبعه تحت السبعه بعضهم شركات
فرعيه اصبح لحدوث 13 شركه ممكن
نعم عندنا مثلا اللي هو طال عمرك شركه
السعوديه الفرنسيه اللي هي الحافلات اللي
هي بي تي سي شركه شركه هذه بالمدينه
الرياض متر الرياض مع الفرنسيين اللي
بعدهم عشرين الشركه الثانيه كان شركه
كامكو اللي هي شركه النقل حقت المترو لم
تشغيل مشروع الرياض وبرضو هذه بس كان
بالعكس مع الفرنسي
فقط شركه للحافلات مناقصه مستقله
والمناقصه الثانيه في المشروع الرياض كانت
مشروع الحافله المترو فالاولى توريد
الحافلات وثالث وتشغيل وصيانه الحافلات
بناء الشبكه
بحدود الف حافله لتغطيه مشروع الرياض
بالكامل الشركه الثانيه لتشغيل هالخطوط
المترو السته اللي هي عباره عن خل نقول
مناقصه مختلفه فكان لابد لها انك تفوز
ايضا فزنا مع الفرنسيين الخطوط المترو مش
للباصات شركه المترو شي وشركه الحفلات شيء
بس عشان افهم الاولى حافلات فقط الثانيه
تشغيل المترو بالضبط اه فانتمارات بالضبط
تكون مشغل الشامل لمدينه الرياض
طبعا
هذا كان جزء كشركتين الشركه الثالثه كان
شركه السعوديه الاماراتيه لنقل متكامل
اللي على اساس الان بدات مشاريع النقل
المدرسي بحدود المليون طالب احنا ننقل
حوالي الخمس 200,000 طالب 5 مليون يوميا
في انحاء المملكه وكان لابد لها ايضا من
ان يكون مع شريك ذوب مكانه وقام اللي هو
شركه مواصلات الامارات
ايضا شركه كانت عباره عن شركه النقل العام
النقل العام هو عباره عن كل خدمات التي
تنقل مجدوله اما داخل المدينه او بين
المدينه اسمها شركه النقل العام مثل مثل
الشركه الان اللي احبها شركاتها التابعه
فازت الاسبوع الماضي مثلا في مناقصات
الامتياز النقل بين المدن عنها الوزاره
اخذنا حنا طبعا ثلاثه اثلاث اخذنا الحين
الثلث اللي يتعلق بالمنطقه الجنوبيه طبعا
المناطق الثلاث كلها تشترك في مدينه
الرياض وتنطلق عسى تتراكم مع بعضها فهذه
مثلا ايضا شركه ايضا كان عندنا شركه دي ام
اس
اوشن حلول التنقل الرقمي اللي زي ما قلت
لك لما
نعرف ان صناعه التنقل الرقمي قادمه تبعا
لحياتنا اليوم اليوم يطلب احد اكله
بالابلكيشن يتقضى الى ايضا التنقل بيكون
للدور فانطلقنا بقوه وبت كبير نسابق الزمن
على اساس نبدا فيه فاطلقنا قياده الذاتيه
كان اول ما اطلقناه في ديسمبر 2019 عن
طريق جامعه كاوت بحكم كل انماط النقل في
مدينه في جامعه تعتبر مدينه متكامله في
عشرين عشرين في بدايه قبل الجائحه ايضا
انطلقنا في مشروع اللي هو النقل التشاركي
وفكرته بكل بساطه هي عباره عن فانات
مرسيدس او براند ثاني بلون
متميز ولكن يعطيك السعه انك تنتقل
بالتشارك مع ناس اخرين من نقطه قريبه منك
الى وجهه قريبه من بعضكم البعض طبعا هذا
لما تقارنها تعطيك نفس المشوار بتكلفه اقل
بكثير نتيجه تدفع جزء وهذا يدفع جزء هذا
التشارك يجعلك انك يعني تقدم منهج جديد في
التنقل
في عشرين عشرين فكانت الضربه القاسمه نحن
كلنا نعرف انه شركات النقل شركات الثقيله
تعتمد على اصول ثابته ما تستطيع انت في
يوم وليله انك بتغير او تبي تقلص او تبي
توقف ان خلصت وسرحت الناس انت فقدت نكهتك
فقدتك ومقوماتك
والاصول ما تتصرف فيها فكانت هي الضربه
الحقيقه قويه لينا والشركات الثانيه لكن
في نفس الوقت بدانا نركز فتره الجائحه كيف
نسرع لكن نعتقد بناصره في 25 26 ليش ما
نحاول نستعجله في 22 21 وهذا اللي صار
معنا الحمد بدانا ايضا من خلال يا طويل
العمر شركه حدود التنقل الرقمي نفرخ خلينا
نقول من هالفينشرز هذه يمكن خمس شركات حتى
الان الشركات حلول ركاب اللي يمكن شفناها
في معرض الاخير معرض اللي بتنقل في
المهرجانات تنقل اللي برضه ايضا تنقل خدمه
عن طريق الابلكيشن
وتستطيع ان تنقل العوائل والناس وتجمعهم
انتشرنا في الدمام في الرياض في جده في
المدينه في مكه ايضا شركه ثانيه اللي هي
نقل الطرود عبر الحافلات عن طريق ابلكيشن
لاننا نذهب لكل مناطق المملكه بس ما
يذهبون الى مثلا الشركات الكبرى في النقل
الشركه الثالثه ايضا كانت عباره عن بلاد
فورم اللي هو
في الفنادق لا حنا النقل والفنادق
والاعاشه للمعتمرين والسواح بحيث نجمعهم
عبر ابلات فورم
ونوفر خدمات لهم شركه رائعه عن مثلا مراه
بعباره عن انه كيف يعني سلك الفرصه تصون
سيارتك عن طريق انك تعرف من الابلكيشن
الورش المتوفره اسعارها مدتها موعد دخولها
وشغالين في تطويره وشركه اخرى اللي هو
عباره عن شركه لتمويل اصحاب النقل بحيث
انه بعد 48 ساعه يؤدي الشحنه او يح تاجه
فلوسه انا ممكن اصبر بالتالي انا اقرضه في
مقابل اني انتظر الى اني حققه فهذه مع هذه
مع هذه مع هذه صارت عباره عن كلها مترابطه
في نسيج واحد يصنع من خلال اللي هو تطوير
عمليات النقل باشكالها المختلفه
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
ومن بين كل هذا الشركات وش اللي ناجح وش
يعني اللي ناجح نفترض بس وش اللي ما نجح
وقفلته يعني مثلا انا شركه خلني اقول
المراب حقت الصيانه
مثقلين بمشاريع كبيره جدا يعني مثلا
المشاريع الان مشاريع او صندوق استماره
العامه حنا نلهث هناك نتواجد في الجديه في
البحر الاحمر في نيوم في كل المشاريع على
اساس ان هي مشاريع ملياريه ومشاريع قويه
تحتاج تركيز فالحقيقه
تدافع المشاريع وتنوعها يجعل احيانا نركز
انه مو معناته انه هو فاشل هذا اللي
قفلناه ولكن لا نستطيع ان نترك وقت اكبر
نتركه على جنب فتره الى نرجع في وقت ممكن
يكون مناسب لنا او للبزنس نفسه في هذا
الصناعه والباقي لها الحمد قاعد يشتغل
بشكل ان شاء الله انه يعني يثبت نجاحه
وتطوره وتثبت هذا المشاريع تحتاج وقت لن
تنمو ويبان ما بين نجاحها وما بين او انك
تعثرها
خلينا الان ننتقل بعد ما فهمنا الشركه
ونشاطها وتاريخها
لحكايه التحول يعني حنتكلم اليوم على بلد
حسب برنامج جوده الحياه نسبه التنقل العام
صفر في المئه واحد واحد ما شاء الله زين
واحد في المئه فقط رغم ان احنا نتكلم على
اربعين سنه اربعين سنه استثمار في هذا
القطاع انت شرحت جزء من مشكله موضوع
الخيارات المنافسه الاخرى اللي هي تعتبر
مفضل اكثر بس خلينا يعني نحكي في اليوم
في عقد للمتروه الرياض يشمل حافلات حدثنا
على الجزء اللي انتم مسؤولين عنه اللي هو
موضوع الحافلات نقل بالحافلات مكون من ايش
وليش 15 شهر واحنا نشوف الباصات تدور
فاضيه ما احنا عارفين ايش قاعده تسوي
ممتاز اما بالنسبه للعقد فهو طبعا عقد
بحدود الثمانيه مليار ونصف في الحافلات
عقد اخر بحدود مقارب ثمانيه ونص يعني
نتكلم على 17 مليار
لتشغيل شبكه الحافلات وشبكه
طبعا اي شبكه تنقل سليمه يجب ان تكون
متكامله ما بين القطار او المترو او
الانواع النمط الثانيه والحافلات طيب
مشروع الحافلات مشروع الحافلات هو عباره
عن اربع مستويات حافلات سريعه طوله 18 متر
تقطع مسارات مستقله عشان تكون سريعه جدا
وتنقل المجمعات كبيره في يعني مسارات
قليله عشان تنقل الناس بسرعه ويسمونه على
فكره برا مترو باس
سرعه المترو بس النباص الخاصه بدل مسار
الخاص عبد العزيز
بالضبط فهذا مثلا الجانب اللي خلينا نقول
العمود الفقري في المستوى الحافله ثم نيجي
الحافلات اللي هي تكون تسميها الكوميونتي
او اللي تصير مثلا الدائريه في مسارات
الرئيسيه على سبيل المثال شارع التخصصي
شارع مثلا تحليه الشوارع الكبير الطريق
الامير تركي فهذه على اساس تبنى من
الشريعه جدا الى الكومينتي اللي هي موازيه
ومتقاطعه ثم تتفرع الى الحواري والاحياء
في شوارع الرئيسيه منها بحافلات ايضا من
استوى ثالث ثم ياتي المستوى الرابع لانه
يفتر في مفاهيم النقل ان الانسان عشان
يترك سيارته في بيته انه او في مكان
باركان رائد مثلا يجب انه ما يمشي اكثر من
400 متر بالذات في ظروفنا الجويه حنا فانت
انت وش بتسوي فيجيب مستوى الرابع اللي هو
الفانات هذه يسمونه دي ار تي اللي هي
حافلات حسب الطلب عن طريق الابلكيشن
اسره كبيره رجل كبير
مرضى الى اخره عشان توصلهم لاقرب نقطه من
هذه الشبكه عن طريق الابلكيشن بتجيك الفان
وبعدين ينقل كلا النقطه ثم عده تنقل في
رسم وجهتك محطه الى محطه من المترو الى
مكانك تهدف اليه فهذه الان المكونات
الثلاثه واضحه المستوى الرابع هل هو بس
مخصص لاصحاب الاحتياجات ولا انا شاب بطلع
من بيتنا او اطلب هالحافله المغذيه ما
بيمشي في الشمس ما بيمشي في المطار ما
بيمشي في الحر اركب بتوصلني اقرب محطه هل
هذا وارد هذا وارد بس مش في المرحله
الاولى المرحله الاولى لا الهم كبار السن
والعوائل والناس المرضى والى اخره وكيف
تميز شلون تدري الان هو الان اللي يفترض
طبعا لا اتكلم باسم الهيئه الملكيه هي
صاحبه المشروع ولكن انا كمشغل اقول لك في
بعض الاشياء والملامح لهذا المشروع التي
سوف تظهر الهيئه الملكيه فاكيد في خطه
التسويقيه للتعريف بالناس بس من حيث لا
التطبيق هيكون هو عباره عن تملك الهيئه
احنا نشرف على تنفيذه عشان نربط ما بين
الطلب هذه يكون فيها ضمنه
كريم حلول ركاب شركه تابعه لان هذا عدد
كبير جدا عشان يوصلك هذه المرحله اي رحله
تنقل يا طويل العمر اخوي عمر لتبدا بقدمك
ثم احيانا
قطار مترو هي مجموعه وجهه بوجهه واحده عبر
عده محطات ينتصلها فكل هذا حيكون ويتطور
بناء على العرض والطلب على المدى الاقبال
ما تنسى اصعب شيء وانت تنشئ شبكه لمدينه
ضخمه كبيره هو قياس الطلب وين بيكون الطلب
وين اتجاهات الطلب ساعات الطلب ذروته
فطبعا حنا الشبكه حتكون تعمل من خمس الفجر
الى 11 بالليل وخليني اعرف فيها فرصه طيبه
يعني مثلا بالنسبه للحافلات احنا نتكلم عن
حوالي 842 حافله مختلف السعات ما بين 12
متر عشره متر 18 متر
وتصل مع بعض المركبات الى الف
تقطع خل نقول تمشي عبر حوالي 80 مسار في
مدينه الرياض
بحوالي
مسافه
1905 كيلو متر
لتصل نقاط في الشبكه حوالي 2860 نقطه
في المقابل شبكه المترو ست خطوط عبر ست
محاور طولها 176 كيلو متر تعتبر من
الشبكات المتوسطه عالميه الصغيره مئه
بالكبيره مره لكن زي مثلا شبكه باريس قبل
عشر سنوات يعتبر شيء يعني ولد كبير
مكونه من 190 عربه قطار
عبر 85 محطه فهذه الشبكتين لما تحط المترو
عادي يصير العمود الفقري للمدينه
والاسرع في الناس ومن يغطى بالشبكه
الحافلات يصبح اليوم انك تستطيع انك
تستغني عن سيارتك ولا لا هذا هو التحدي هل
اقتنعت بكثافه الرحلات هذا اللي بيجاوب
عليه احترامك لوقتك خيارك انك تنحى عن
سيارتك وتساهم طبعا ما يخفاك اخ عمر يعني
الناس مثلا يتساءلون هل سيقبل الناس على
الشبكه صح انا ما اعتقد اليوم الزحام اللي
احنا نشوف في الرياض المشوار نفسه اللي
كان عشره كيلو انا اقضيه مثلا بين مكتبي
وبيت كنت اقضيه في عشر دقائق مثل السلاسل
تقضيه في 20 دقيقه اليوم نقضيه في 30
دقيقه ايش معناته معناته ان سرعه السياره
اللي كانت 60 كمعدل عام اصبحت 40 الان
اصبحت عشرين شويتين اذا ما عندنا مشروع زي
هذا ونلجا الى النقل العام بيكون هذه
الطرق عباره عن خل نقول السيارات بينما
يكون سياره
فانا اعتقد ان اليوم ايضا ترى في التعليم
لما سافروا الناس وبداوا مثلا الطلاب هذا
مع امه هذا معه ابوها هذا تعلموا على
ساليب النقل واصبحوا مهيئين منهم اليوم
لما تيجي الشبكه يعرفون يستخدمونها
وبالتالي يقبلون لها لان اليوم احنا نبني
شبكه وورد كلاس بمعنى الكلمه افضل انواع
الحافلات انواع القطارات انواع التقنيات
كل الان اللي موجوده في كاليفرنس ومرجعيه
للعالم كله من خلال اعلى المواصفات اللي
وضعت في هذا المشروع وكم المفروض من
سيارته تزيح شبكه النقل العامه من مدينه
الرياض كبدايه يقدر انها تزيح حوالي ربع
مليون سياره ربع مليون سياره كرحلات من
اصل كم ما يحضن الرقم بحدود الاربعه مليون
يمكن سياره او اربعه ونص مليون سياره على
5% من زحمه الرياض اكثر بكثير اذا هيمتين
من اصل اربعه مليون
اوكي خلنا نقول وايضا اهم منه تجويد
الحياه عن طريق انك تبي تقلص 400 الف لتر
من الوقود اللي هو احد مسبات العوادم اللي
اللي تلوث في المدينه في اليوم انت من
الناحيه الصحيه عشان نضبط سقف توقعات سكان
المدينه انه ترى كلها المشروع هذا اثره هو
خمسه في الميه من حركه السيارات
تقريبا تقيسه بالرحلات اوكي كم عدد
الرحلات دام اتكلم في صناعه النقل عن عدل
رحلات لقد يكون عندك سيارات كثيره انت
يمكن تملك اربع سيارات في بيتك غيرك يملك
سيارتين وعلى فكره احنا في السعوديه من
اعلى الدول العالم اقتناء للسيارات مقابل
الدخل
فتجد مثلا بعض الدول تدخل هالقد امتلاك
الاسره للسياره جزء بسيط لكن مثلا في
امريكا وعلى فكره احنا نتشابه في امريكا
كل شيء
وليست راسيه وبالتالي شبكات النقل يعني
تروح لامريكا على فكره تلقى مثلا واشنطن
اسف بالذات نيويورك اقرب ما تكون للطابع
الاوروبي متاثره فيه فتلقى فيها صناعه
النقل يمثل جزء كبير منها وكل ما تروح غرب
كل ما يقل النقل العام ترجع الى ابو فيصل
ما راح انسى السؤال المهم انا ما درت حتى
لو وصلنا نيويورك حتى وصلنا
الرياض افهم سؤال شلون هذه الباصات تدور
15 شهر هذا الجزء الثاني من سؤالك
يجب ان نعرف انت لما لما تدخل
شبكه جديده من العدم كجسم غريب على
المدينه
يجب انك تدخل في مراحل تجريبيه تتاكد فيها
من قياساتك وارتباط مكونات عناصر الشبكه
بافضل ما يمكن على اساس يكون حسب توقعات
الناس لما يبدون يدخلون على هالشبكه تراها
جزء مفصلي في الاقبال من عدمه هل الشبكه
فعلا تستاهل هل نوعيه الحافلات فخمه هل هي
مكيفه هل فيها الواي فاي هل هي مهيئه
للمعاقين هل هي مربوطه بالتايم بحيث انك
انت تقعد في مكتبك ما بدات تنزل في الشمس
تنتظر من جيك الحافله انت عندك جوالك وفيه
الجدول ترى الحافله الفلانيه الان اللي
بتجيك بعد عشر وبعدها يمكن عشر دقائق تجي
وحده ثانيه تقرر متى تنزل هذا جزء من جذبك
لذلك ترى في مكونات العقد اساسا
مكوناته البدايه بمرحله تجريبيه تطول او
تقصر حسب ما يقرر صاحب المشروع الملكيه
المده تتراوح تراه تتراوح من ثلاثه شهور
الى سته شهور صح يمكن طالت اكثر ما حد
يشغل سنه فتره طويله لكن لا انسى اني اقول
انه الناس ينظرون الى الحافله التي تدور
بس نزلوا ان الحافله اللي تدور ترى مربوطه
باختبارات قاعده تجريها مع مركز التحكم
والسيطره مع انظمه الاليه مع انظمه البيع
تذاكر مع الانظمه الجدولة ترى العمليه
الباص اللي تشوفه يدور في الشارع بالنظام
الجديد كوردي كلاس
نظام مربوط بمجموعه انظمه عشان يكون في
افضل ما يمكن انك تتوقعه من خدمه راقيه
خدمه على مستوى وتكون فيها كل شيء
اوتوميتد
فيطول وينقص ترى لا ننسى شيء ثاني انا ودي
اعرج عليه ليس تبريرا
انا مشغل فقط متى ما بدات اكتملت الهيئه
برامجها واستعدادها لكني انا لا ابرر النم
افسر
في ثلاث سنوات الاخيره تراث سنوات اليوم
لما تشوفها
رياض قاعد تنمو اسرع بكثير من اي تخطى
مخطط او تخطيط او جدوله
اشرح لي واش على مثلا التشغيل بشرحلك مثلا
اليوم تجي تبني شبكه نقل من العدم لمدينه
خذ على سبيل المثال دائما احب باريس
شريكنا فرنسيين وكل السعوديين اكثرهم
يمرون تجد معالم المدينه اللي تربطها
متقاربه واضحه من عشرات السنين فتربطها
بسهوله اليوم انا اكلمك ترى انا سمعنا امس
عن مشروع ضخم جدا
مربع القديه قبلها
الدرعيه
مطار الملك سلمان هذه ترى كل يوم هي تضيف
الى اعاده تشكيل خارطه المدينه كيف تبنيها
وتربطها بعضها البعض شيء ثاني استخدامات
الاراضي طبعا دائما احنا نعاني في النقل
بان ناتي في الاخير بعد ما يكون الاصلاح
اصعب بينما يكون هو الاول عن طريق بناء
يعني اسلوب السواحي وتربطها انا ما عاد
تفرق معي اسكن في الظاهر ولا اسكن في قلب
المدينه بس انا بقى نروح للمكان الافضل
الاكبر الاحسن ودائما في الضواحي او خارج
السنتر طالما اني ضمنت انك حتصلني الى
عملي او مقاصدي مستشفيات مراجعات بوسائل
نقل لذلك اليوم احنا في السباق ما بين
شبكه النقل سوف تولد ومبعد بدات قاعده
تتوسع كيف تمد الخط رقم اثنين الملك عبد
الله المحور الين ياسر الدرعيه يمكن يتعدى
يصل جديه اليوم قاعدين يشتغلون الاخوان في
الهيئه الملكيه انه المدينه اللي قاعده
تنمو وتكبر كيف تلحقها فبرجع مره ثانيه
من ضمن العقد
المبني من سنوات مو بس الامس لما بدينا
نجرب ولا قبل سند او زي ما تفضلت 15 شهر
موجود في بدايتها ان ازاجرين فيلد او
خلينا نقول بدايه خصبه لارض خصبه ما بعد
بدينا دراسه الفلو حق او تدفق الحركه في
الحافلات اليوم اليوم انت تقيس ايضا فترات
التوقف فبالتالي كان الهدف من الهيئه
الملكيه فيما اعرفه واسمع عنهم انهم يبغون
يبدون كل شيء متكامل بافضل طريقه عشان
يتركون
والنظره الى انه فعلا مستوى عالمي يرغب
ويساعد الناس للتحول من سياراتهم الى
الحافلات وشبكه القطارات الملاحظات اللي
يمكن البعض شاركها هي موضوع الحوادث اللي
صارت في الباصات وهي فاضيه وقبل الناس
وحتى كان في ملاحظه ما يعرف اذا هي دقيق
او انت بحكم خبرتك في هالقطاع تقدر تفيدنا
اكثر مواقف الباصات ما هي بصايره خارج
الشارع هي صايره وسط الشارع فانت تجي فجاه
ماشي وراها الباص اللي يوقف عند محطه فكل
انت واللي وراك يعني كلكم حتوقفون صحيح
بعدين حيكون واقف قبل دخلت الحي فممكن في
سياره جايه من اليسار تبي تتجاوزه وتدخلي
يمين
الباص هذا بيمشي وقد يصير في تصادم تصميم
المحطات بهذه الطريقه انه الباص يوقف في
الشارع ما هو على جنب الشارع هل هي مقصوده
ولا هذا اللي قدرنا عليه لانه المدينه
قائمه ولا وش الفكره هذا يتفضل فيه وهذا
يمكن اللي يطول فتره التجربه انك تبغى
تتعود الناس على وجود هذه الاجسام الغريبه
اللي ما كانوا متعودين عليها حافلات ضخمه
فجاه توقف هي جزء من رسم الحياه في
المدينه لتعود عليه لما تكون برا بمدينه
تعمل بنظام النقلها عشرات السنين مليون زي
ما تفضلت احنا نواجه حوادث احنا بعد بدانا
اللي هو التوقف له جزء من في محطات اصلا
وجود المحطه فضل عن توقف قدامها وانتظار
اللي انت تتواصل رحلاتها
الجزء الثاني من سؤالك اللي هو انه مكانها
مكانها كان يعتبر انه قاعدين يخترعون لانه
انت في الاساس انك تصمم المبنى فيه مصعد
غير انك تبي تخلق مصعد عقب ما بنيت البيت
احنا نسوي نفس الشيء لمدينه كبرت وكبرت
وكبرت وتوسعت وصارت حتى مقاصد المدينه
وجهاتها تغيرت في مراكزها التجاريه وهذه
هذا جعلنا اليوم انه انه وهذا يجوز على
فكره من التجربه اللي هو متى نجاح تعويد
الناس على وجود هذه المحطات في حياتهم
اليوميه وللاسف حوادث كثيره جدا قاعد تحصل
ضرب في هذه الحافلات من الخلف للناس ما
بعد تعود في العكس وفي الحفلات ضربت ناس
ترى قليل جدا قليل جدا قليل
طيب الان احنا طيب نبي القول الفصل متى
بتشتغل هالبصل والله حسب تصريحات صاحب
المشروع الهيئه الملكيه قالوا عنها ان شاء
الله في الشهر مارس نتمنى ان شاء الله
يكون جاهزين انتم احنا جاهزين تماما
كم نسبه الالتزام بالمواعيد حسب ارقامكم
حنا ناخذ غرامات في عدم الالتزام احنا نصل
حتى الان الحمد لله 98 97 98 99 بالمئه
ولكن يوم اقول لك انه الجدوله هي جدوله
تعتمد على تدفق الحركه المراقبه بالاقمار
الصناعيه وتعطيك الرسائل جوا الحافله متى
بتصل بالابلكيشن متى الجايه فكل هذه تراها
عباره عن جهد جهيد
المساهمين حديث على الدراهمه يقول طيب
فتره التشغيل هذه على من انت دفعت الفلوس
من ارباحنا ولا هذه ضمن عقود التشغيل لا
لا هي ضمن مرحله عقود التشغيل موجوده نصا
ماخذ اعتبارها
وتشغيليا زي ما قلت لكم المراحل التهيئه
للهيئه الى ان تضبط الايقاع وترى انه الان
حان الاوان ان الركاب يدخلون في الحافلات
فالحمد لله لا بالعكس يعني
جدا طيب
فينا حدث مهم ايضا ثاني اللي هو موضوع
فوزكم بتحالف
النقل الجنوب في النقل بين المدن ودي افهم
انا يعني انتم او بنص انا بستخدم
نصدقاء اللي ارسلنا يقول هذولي ما في كل
المملكه بيفلحون في منطقه صغيره يعني هو
يقول انتوا عندكم امتياز حصري واحتكار ولا
احد يقرب يقربكم والمملكه كلها عندكم وما
نجحتم فهل بتنجحون وانتوا اخذتوا جزء صغير
من الكعكه يعني هو خايف على مستقبل الشركه
ماليا انا اللي خايف ليش يخاف على انه
يعني
يجب ان ننظر بتقدير كبير للشركه في ان كيف
ربطت حقيقه فوق 300 مدينه وقريه ترى
المطارات من مطار الى مطار القطارات من
محطه الى محطه بس احنا نوقف على غرف
الطريق ربطنا الناس باعمالهم مصالحهم
قضيناها
بحدود السته مليون سته مليون
ما يعادل نصف لتنقل الخطوط السعوديه داخل
المملكه فتتخيل هذا الحجم نعم حنا نطلق
حافله كل دقيقتين بين مدن المملكه تتخيل
هذا الشيء احنا نقطع 330 مليون كيلو متر
مليون 330 في قاره مثل المملكه ترى هذا لا
يمكن لما يخاف الاخ في السؤال ولحقني يخاف
في وجهه نظره لكن ليه الحق انه يقول هذا
جهد كبير لا يمكن تستمر فيه ما لم تكون
انت بهذا الكفاءه وهذه القوه لتقطع 330
كيلو متر لذلك هذا المسافات الضخمه فيها
الصحاري في هالجبال تحت هذه الامطار احنا
وصلنا لمرحله كنا اكبر عمير لمرسيدس في
العالم متخيل مثل ما طيران الامارات واكبر
لطيران ايرباس
وكانت لها طراز اسمه اعلى انواع المرسيدس
لسبب او المسافات الشاقه والطويله كل
اقطعها هذا كله ترى يشار له بالبنان برا
المملكه لما يجون يشوفون السعوديه اللي
تمثل ثلث اوروبا كمساحه تقطعها شركه وتوصل
للناس فيها
فليس هذا فلاح انا اعتقد انه كان نوع من
الفلاح والنجاح بس اليوم ايش اللي اختلف
الحين اللي يختلف اليوم انه لا يعني تنظر
الحكومه الى انه يجب ان يوما ما يفتك
الامتياز عشان نخلق المنافسه المنافسه
دائما صحيه في كل شيء شوف الاتصالات اليوم
كيف نعيش حنا من التنافس علينا كزبائن في
كيف يغدقون علينا المزايا بعد ما كان
العكس احنا نفس الشيء مرحله تاسيس قضيناها
ومرحله توسعات في الشبكه اسسناها بعد 45
عام اليوم ننتقل في المنافسات اللي وضعت
بانها تكون ثلاث خلنا نقول مناطق يحق لكل
واحد اذا من المشاركين اذا فاز ان لا يفوز
الا بمرحله واحده منطقه واحده فكان نصيب
الحمد لله فزنا باحد
الثلاثه طبعا طبعا كان عندكم تفضيل لمكان
معين احنا نعم كنا نستهدف المنطقه
الجنوبيه ليش يعد الاعتبارات تشغيل
يعني انا اعتقد الكثافه السكانيه اكثر
المسافات الطويله ذات القيم التذاكر
الاعلى
الخطوط احنا اللي جربنا شغلنا كل المناطق
الثلاثه فمن واقع تجربتنا على مدار
السنوات نجد ان المنطقه الجنوبيه اكثر
الجاذبيه مع مع انه الهيئه العامه تطورت
ترى في قضيه طرح المنافسه الين خلقت فيها
الى حد كبير توازن بين الثلاث مناطق
للمملكه اربعه ارباع ربع خالي وبالتالي
صار عندك المحور الشمالي الشرقي المحور
الشمالي الغربي والمنطقه الجنوبيه وكان
احنا في نظرك لا تشترك في الرياض كلها
تشترك في الرياض عشان تخلق خطوط احيانا
مشتركه تؤدي وجده لمشتركه او مكه جده ومكه
طالع مشتركه بحكم انها وجهه عن العمره
فبالتالي يكون فيها اتجاه لكن اللي بقول
ايضا يعني
الجنوبيه انا اعتقد انه كجزء طبعا عزيز
علينا كل بس حنا كان نتمنى لو يعني كان
يحصل مثلا فرصتين من ثلاث بس حقيقه
الادخال مجموعه منافسين كان اقل شيء يكون
عندك ثلاثه بدال واحد ونتمنى ان شاء الله
النجاح لنا ولهم في تطوير السنه كم مدينه
تغطي نطاقكم
مجموع المدن بيصير بحدود اللي هو مدن
كنقاط ويختلف تعريف النقاط على فكره انا
ممكن اقول لك الرياض الطائف نقطتين لكن
ممكن اقول لك الرياضه الطائف واللي عليه
القويعيه المزاحميه فقولك يمكن السبع بس
هي بالحدود المعلن عنها من هيئه النقل
العام الاسبوع الماضي انها بتكون بحدود
مدينه 200 مدينه وقريه تربط عبر الشبكه من
هالثلاث تحالفات بحدود كل واحد يعني من
ثمانيه وسبعين الى 85 خط
رحله
وبمواصفات ممتازه ان شاء الله على السابق
كتجربه يعني
نقاط الانطلاق يعني يقول الرياض دوله وما
حطيتونا الا منطقه في جنوب الرياض هي اللي
طب شمال الرياض ليش في مركز مثلا صحيح انا
انا اعتقد ان احنا على فكره تراجع ادائنا
في مدينه الرياض لما انتقلنا مع الاسف الى
جنوب الرياض كنا في البطحاء في مركز
المدينه كان وعلى حجم المدينه قبل عشر
سنين 15 سنه كل واحد في ربع له عندك في
المحطه وتنطلق في شمالا شرقا جنوبا لما
رحنا في جنوب الرياض وكبرت الرياض تخيل
واحد عند نادي الشباب في شمال الرياض
يحتاج ساعه يرجع الى جنوبها عشان ياخذنا
حنا الساعه لين نطلع عنده نادي الشباب
ونروح القصيم مع التسوى فبالتالي تخلص
حقيقه الاركاب عندنا وكان اصلا المفروض ان
يكون عندك مركزين مركز شمال الرياض مركز
جنوب الرياض اذا كان في بعض المدن
المطارات ثلاث مطارات في مراكز النقل
حاولنا الحقيقه قبل كم سنه انه يكون عندنا
مثلا في محطه القطار في الشمال بس كانت
فتره انه بينتهي الامتياز لا بيمدد
الامتياز جعلتنا شوي احجمنا وبالتالي قلنا
انه قادم قادم ان شاء الله والحين الان
احنا خلاص يعني اليوم لما تنطرق شبكه
النقل مدينه الرياض اللي يفترض نبداها اذا
الله راد الشهر مارس
ربطنا كل انحاء المدينه
النقل الان هو مازال مركز النقل العام
اللي ينطلق منه المشغلين الثلاثه بين
المدن انا اعتقد
يجب ان يكون في الشمال بشكل عاجل جدا وهذا
المسؤول عنه
للناقل هي المفروض تحدد وربما كان محطه
الشمال محطه القطار الحالي
يكون عندك
المطار حافلات مطار وبالتالي للمطار صار
يجي عند المحطه صحيح فيها انت ايضا فزتوا
بالنقل الترددي في الطائف وفي المدينه او
عقد النقل العام في الطائف ونقل تردد في
المدينه صحيح وش الفرق بينهما بالنسبه لا
بشرك الحمد لله يعني مع يعني خلينا نقول
اعلان عن انتهاء الامتياز وبالتالي الحين
فزنا بالثلث وراح الثلثين بس احنا فزنا في
المقابل اللي هي مناقصات داخل المودم خمس
سنوات اللي ما فيها دعم تغير الموديل
رجعنا الى ما كنا عليه عام 79 ان احنا
نعتقد انه مثلا هذا حجم الاركان يحتاج
لفتره ينمو في خسائر طبعا فنقوم التنافس
يكون بين المشغلين انه من اللي يقدم صاحب
طلب الدعم الاقل عن طريق انه يجود خدماته
ويزيد في الاركاب قدر الامكان وبالتالي
يكون ففزنا حنا اولا في المدينه وسمى نقل
تردده لانه المدينه عباره عن مدينه
الشعاعيه مصدرها الحرم مركزها وبالتالي
تاتي انت من اطراف المدينه بشكل ترددي
تروح وتيجي اما النقل عامله هو عباره عن
شبكه
متقاطعه مربعات
طال عمرك بالطائف فزنا في القصيم فزنا
بالدمام قلنا والمدينه احنا في جده
موجودين حنا الرياض حنشغله لانه الفائزين
والان الهيئه في الحمد لله يعني ثلاث
سنوات الاخيره في تسارع بعد ما امضوا
وقتهم في الدراسات اليوم حنسمع قريبا عن
جازان عن تبوك عن الاحسى عن حفر الباطن
فحتيجي هذه ان شاء الله من عام 23 وجاي
اليوم
باصات جديده الباصات ان تكون حديثه حديثه
تعريف حديث ان يكون عمرها اقل من عشر
سنوات فبالتالي يفترض انذال عقد عمره خمس
سنوات انك تجيب اقل شيء انه ما تزيد عنها
خمس سنوات عشان تجيبها او تجيبها جديده
بحسب في الدمام جبنه جديده في جده كنا
جايبين جديده المدينه جبنه جديده وهلم كم
حافله تحت طاقه تشغيلكم حنا اليوم في
سابتكو على فكره في ضمن التعريف احنا
حوالي الجروب يشمل الشركات حوالي 15 الف
شخص زائدا ثمانيه الاف مركبه ثمانيه الاف
حافله حافله ومركبه لان عندنا فانات عندنا
قياده ذاتيه
ولا سوينا صناعه محليه ولا محتوى محلي ليش
اليوم الخطوات فعلا عن هذه عباره عن شركات
مثلا السير الان عن طريق البي اي اف هو
الحقيقه
بس الحافلات اليوم ايضا من ضمن التوطين
ومن ضمن اللوكاليزيشن
انك تجي الشركات العالميه وتبدا تبني
مصانع اليوم الشركه
عن طريق البي اي اف وتطوير التعليم وشركه
ثالثه والله نسيت عندهم الشركه الان اللي
بعديه يبنونها اسمها دستور هي الشركه احد
منتجات عباره عن البناء حافلات تصليح
حافلات تصليح حافلات تواصلت معهم او
تواصلوا معكم
لكن احنا اليوم اننا ننظر في على خنقول
على طرف الحياد الكثير من الشركات
والمصانع اللي يبغون مثلا ابسطها انت
كمشتري انت تقول اهم مشتري مرسيدس ما
اقنعت مرسيدس يجي يفتح مقطع في السعوديه
تعرف القضيه والشيء مرسيدس موجود
خلنا نقول
اللي انا ابحث ليتمناه ان يكون هو المصانع
المتقدمه حقت المانيا وتركيا تبع مرصد هذه
المصانع مكلفه جدا جدا تقنيتها عاليه جدا
ما يعني يتوافق يعني ماليا حجم مع حجم خل
نقول مثلا مشروع الرياض كلها الف حافله
اذا هو قدرته على الانتاج الفين طيب
وبعدين فهو لا يحتاج انه يكون على مستوى
العالم كله موجود فيهم ثلاث بنات اماكن
لكن الحافلات الحجاج حفلات نقل المدرسه هي
اللي الان بدات تتواجد في المملكه وتقام
صناعات لها لانها سهله بسيطه سريعه
وتتناسب مع التنافس اللي مثلا المنتج
الصيني والمنتج الاخر من البلدان الثانيه
هذا واحد يسال ابو فيصل على موضوع تجربه
النقل خلال كاس العالم
نقل في كاس العالم
كانت والله تجربه جميله بين الهيئه العامه
للنقل كمتتول
التنظيم العمليه ومعنا في الشركه السعوديه
نقل جماعي فكان عندنا يعني حوالي يمكن
نفذنا 140 الف رحله ما بين الحدود والحدود
وداخل من الحدود ابو سمره القطري الين
مدينه الدوحه وبعدين عاد بالحافلات
القطريه هم اللي يوزعون نقل حوالي نصف
مليون اوف في نصف مليون وكانت صراحه تجربه
جميله تكاتفت فيها جهود الجهه الحكومه
ممثله في الهيئه العامه للنقل مع الاجهزه
الحكوميه لانك تعرف جهد جهيد في الحدود مع
الجوازات مع حقون البلديه تنظيم المواقع
وضع الباركينج الناحيه الامنيه
تسهيل العمليه وكان اقبال جميل جدا رائع
وانا اعتقد كانت يعني بالنسبه لنا تجربه
جميله اننا يعني خذناها
ونفتخر فيها حنا بالشراكه مع هيئه العامه
للنقل لتنظيم المناسبات الاخرى على هذا
الغرار وما تنسى اليوم المملكه مقدمه على
استضافه كثير من المهرجان لا تنسى ترى
السعوديه اليوم من ضمن التجارب اللي
استفدنا فيها وابدعنا فيها في الحدود اللي
هي الكراود
اداره تنظيم الحشود اليوم المملكه من خلال
الحاج ترانا احنا على مستوى ذو كعب عالي
في تنظيم اداره الحشود بشكل رائع ومذهل
فلذلك انا اقول هذا جزء من الاشياء نفخر
فيها وكانت يمكن مشاركه كاس العالم جزء من
ابراز هذه الامكانيات والله الحمد هذا
بيسال عن دراهمه يقول متى بتوزعون ترجعون
توزعون ارباح ان شاء الله حنا في مرحله
التعافي واليوم الحمد لله مشاريعنا اللي
بنيناها من عشر سنوات او ثمان سنوات او ست
سنوات اللي هي اللونق المدى الطويل
ملياريه الان اذا بدا مشروع الرياض اليوم
بيبدا مشروع المترو اليوم بتبدا المشاريع
الاخرى اللي بدنا نحصل عليها انا اعتقد
نبدا الحين ببناء احتياطياتنا ونبدا في
توزيعاتنا بحول الله في بشكل عام ابو فيصل
يعني امتعاض وانزعاج من تجربه
العميل بشكل عام في الوصول لكم س التطبيق
اظن اظن عندكم يعني على كلامه انه طريقه
الحجز بدائيه ولا يمكن الحجز من عن طريق
الموقع موضوع مقرات وفروع الشركه ومراكز
انطلاق الحافلات يقول جدا بدائيه ففي
امتعاط بشكل عام التجربه وكيف تقيم شقين
الاول عن عمليه
الحزب الحجز اون لاين ما اعتقد لها الدرجه
يعني شركات الطيران انت الحين لما تستخدم
شركه هاديه عن هذه في تباين في قبولك وفي
طريقه عرضهم احنا احد هذولي احنا عندنا
نحن نحاول تشاهدنا اننا نطور من خلق
السلاسه الدخول في الموقع والتواصل
والحصول عليه هذا جزء وعلى فكره ترى 20%
من حجوزاتها تم عن طريق الاون لاين ولما
تكون كويسه ما اعتقد كانت تستمر
صادق بس
خليني اقول لك شيء انت تعرف مثلا من اكبر
الشركات العالميه في النقل شركه جريهان في
امريكا
لما رحنا نسوي اعمال الميكنه وناخذ منهم
تجربتهم انا تفاجات مثلا على سبيل المثال
انت في امريكا اتعرف انهم لما حطوا مع
كائن الدفع والحجوزات وجدوا ان الفئه اللي
تعامل مع فئه النقل البري سته وسبعين
بالمئه يبغون يدفعون بالكاش ويحجزون بدوي
هالكلام طبعا قبل يمكن ست سنوات وفي
امريكا في امريكا انت اليوم السعوديه
وانا معك ولكن بقول لك شيء اللي هو يرتبط
بالشق الثاني ترحلنا جلسنا
خلنا نقول يعني 15 سنه الاخيره مثل اللي
مستاجر وليس مالك في بيته
تمديد سنتين لا تمديد ثلاث تمديد خمس طبعا
متمدد ليه لان لما جاء الان مثل مشروع
اللي يعلن عن الاسبوع الماضي لا مواصفات
المختلفه نظام مختلفه ما استطيع ان اسوي
استثمار لمده سنه او سنتين ولا يستطيع
السر انا اصير بعثرت اموال المساهمين فانا
امسك العصا بالنص ما بين اني ابغى اتطور
يمكن يكون على استحياء بس لاني انا اعرف
اني انا لا افرض مواصفاتي او انظفتي ترى
انظمه الدفع برضو يقرها المالك المشروع
هيئه المدينه هيئه الدمام فنتكيف معهم مع
احتياجاتهم بناء على مواصفاتهم لكن في
مجمل العام احنا كنا نبادر قبل بكثير خط
البلده في 2018 لما تم القضاء على خط
البارده بالتعاون ما بين الهيئه العامه
للنقل وما بين شركه سابتكو اللي جالس اكثر
من خمسه
مظهر مخيف كيف ننتقل الى وورد كلاس هل
الشبكه الجديده وحين ننتقل من خط البلد
فكانت هذه الفتره الزمنيه الخمس سنوات
الاخيره
تراكات المواصفات تشمل هذا الشيء
بالمواصفات عاديه حافله وسائق ويستبدلها
وخلاصنا دخلنا حنا اعمال اللي هو انك تدفع
الاقل انك تعرف مسار الحافله عن طريق
الميكنه من قبل الشركه بعيد عن المواصفات
ليه عشان احنا نرسل رساله توعويه للناس
يتعودون عليها ويؤمنون فينا قبل ما يجي
خلنا نقول الاداء الكبير اللي هو نظام
النقل العام في المشروع اللي احنا بنبدا
انشاء والفروع والمقرات الفروع المقرات
تعرف انه لا نملكها اصلا انتم مستاجرينها
انتم بعضها نستاجره لكن بعضها عباره عن من
الدوله حسب ما كان الامتياز انه يتم منح
الشركه ما قرات مؤقته تستخدمها وكان نفس
الوضع اذا انا ما اعرف اقعد بعد سنتين
ثلاثه فكنا نتعايش معها ولكن نعطيها الحد
الادنى او الحد المقبول اننا تكون مقوله
معقوله بالمحطات ترى لما تسافر محطات
النقل بري تختلف عن محطات المدن الكبرى عن
محطات التوقف في كلاسيكيشن فاحنا لوجود
انه لا نملكها كان نتعايش معها خلينا نقول
بالشكل اللي لا يقل عن مستوى يرضينا لكن
مو يحقق طموحنا فيه بدون شك هذا يسال يقول
لماذا لا يوجد مقاعد مخصصه لذوي
الاحتياجات خاصه كل باصاتكم نفس التصميم
ولا توجد مساحه لنا احنا فئه دوله تمت
فينا فنرجوا الاهتمام بنا
اول شيء هم هم فئه عزيزه على قلوب كل
الناس ولكن مع الاسف ما كان ترى في
المملكه عموما لما تروح الدوائر الحكوميه
تجد مواقفهم ما تجد تسهيلاتهم فهي ترى
الخدمه نفسها عباره عن كل متكامل انا
اعتقد في عام 2015 صدر تعميم بداوا يصير
فيه حراك بدا فيه اهتمام في المحلات في
المولات في المحطات عندنا اللي هي الوصفات
الجديده كلها لازم فيه المواصفات الجديده
كلها الان ومشروع الملك عبد العزيز اللي
مشروع الرياض سيكون ايقونه في مفهوم
التعامل مع ذوي الاحتياجات او مفهوم
اللي بيصير كله في الحافلات تصميمها في
المسارات في المحطات في المكان التذاكر في
المسارات
في الاجراس والتنبيه كل ما يعني خدمه
لتقديم هذه الفئه هو الحقيقه في الرياض
وذاك احنا يمكن تاخرنا عنه في الرياض لانه
المشروع الجاي جاي لكن ساعات احنا بدينا
من عام 2016 لكن كل حافلاتنا مزوده بيبي
الرام بهذا اللي ينزل من حافله الحافله
نفسه من النوع اللي هو يميل
ومسارات في المحطه ففي المدينه
في مقاعد ولما يقول كل التصميم مثل بعض
نعم لان كل حافلات تصمم وتصنع مثل بعض في
اللي عندنا يقصد كراسي الكراسي طال عمرك
نوعين الكراسي اللي هي عباره عن نفس
الكرسي
هذا تنزل الرام يجيك في الوجه في الباب
الاوسط مكانين يثبتون عشان ما يتحرك وجنب
الزرار عشان يتعامل مع السائق فموجوده في
اللوحه للمدينه مثلا من عمر 13 بعدها في
جده ترى موجوده من عام 2019 في الدمام
الان موجود من عام الماضي فحنا بدينا
بالمناطق اللي اكلت لنا فورا من عام 2016
بدانا نتفاعل معها ونعززها طبعا لما تجي
تناظر تلقى المقعدين من ضمن 37 مقعد يعني
يمثل حدود نسبه
تقريبا خمسه بالمئه
والحفلات الجديده على فكره بين المودن
اليوم من ضمن المواصفاتها يكون في
اليفيترا ومصعد عشان لانه مرتفعه هي مثل
الطائرات فيرتفع وبعدين يدخل في المقعد
اللي هو يناسبه فبالعكس حنا موجودين
ونغطيها ولكن مقصرين لا شك ولكن ناتي يعني
متاخرين ضمن لا نتي ابدا اعتقد اليوم
الدوله على كل مستوياتها تعطي هذا
الاهتمام حنا من ضمنهم بحول الله هذا يسال
ما سبب فشل خدمه ليموزين المطار
والله يا اخي كلمه فشل مزعجه حقيقه
ازعجتني اننا بذلنا جهد من عام 2010
باننا جبنا السيارات المرسيدس الاس كلاس
350 الاودي اي اي بلون اسود
بالبدله بالترتيب اللي على الاقل يحسن
المظهر الحضاري لما الكل من يقدم على
مطاراتك ولكن لكن على قوله الله لكن على
فكره
هي نفسها مثلا هل العله هذه اسمها لكن ما
كان في تفاهم الحقيقه اليوم يتغيروا
المسؤولين اليوم في المطارات مختلف احنا
في ذاك الوقت انه الصانع حط بس مجرد انك
لما تروح تعرف وين حنا في برا لما تطلع
بره على الرسيف تلقانا في اخر المسار قد
القطوه الكداده واسحاب السيارات اللي هو
الواجهه اللي ما ودك انك يعني تشوفها
مبعثره وتشتته
فلما يكون عندي انا مصاريف مستمره
ومحاولات للتنظيم محاولات لهذه كان مزعج
العمليه وبالتالي ينسحبنا من كيف بسميها
من بزنس الى فرد خلونا او مشاركه الى فرد
الى شركه الى شركه فاستمرينا فيها ولكن مع
شركات نقدم لها الخدمات بشكل يعني يعفينا
من العثرات اللي صارت بعدين عاد هبت فيما
بعد لما جاء تاكسي الشركات التاكسي الاخضر
وبعدين فالتنظيمات هذه يمكن خلينا نقول
نفسنا ما كان يتحمل نستمر اكثر لانه كان
مقلق انه خلني اقول توقيت ما كان مناسب او
كنا مبكرين يمكن على التوقيت هنا اليوم لا
الحمد لله انا اشوف كيف اصلا من ضمن صناعه
المطارات الجديده حديثها مفهوم السوق
الحره كيف صار كبير وتقضيه في اوقاتك
موضوع كيف انك توفر وسائل النقل طبعا هنا
في وسائل النقل اليوم مثل المطارات غير
الرياض اللي كنا ننقله جدا الدمام ننقل
خطوط العاشره الى محطات المحطات نوزعهم
على انحاء المملكه هنا في سؤال على موضوع
التوطين بشكل عام من 15 الف كم منهم
سعوديين زائد انا لفت نظري موضوع الباصات
في المترو في الرياض او باصات حافلات
الرياض ما شفت فيها
اول شيء
لما تسال كم النسبه هي شركات مختلفه
التكوين ففي شركات تجدهم 80% زي بعد شركات
حلول للتنقل الرقمي 80% وتجد شركات يمكن
عشرين بالمئه هذا التفاوت وشكرا تجد بعض
الشركاتنا مئه بالمئه وبعض الشركات يمكن
قدك تتعثر بالعشرين بالمئه الفارق بكل
بساطه ان صناعه النقل هو هو صناعه النقل
اكبر ما تواجهه ندره السائقين المحليين لو
تكون في المانيا ترى عندك مشكله في
المانيا من السائقين المال تروح لاي بلد
عندك السعودي عنده فرص كبيره وعندنا مشاكل
كثيره في توفيرهم لكن ابوابنا مفتوحه لهم
بالكوم وش رايك اخ عمر انك قبل ما تيجي
نطاقات 2011 12 13 وندخل في نطاقات مشاكل
كانت نسبه السائقين السعوديين في شركه
اربعين بالمئه
اربعين بالمئه يعني الان يعتبر فوق الماسي
السبب فقط هو عباره عن عرض والطلب كانت
الايام الناس ما يعرفون الا وظائف حكوميه
يقدم على وظيفه وينتظر تعيينه وين يروح
يترزق الله في هالفتره يروح شكل النقل
الجماعي ويصير سائق فيها الين يجي قراره
من يعطيك المفتاح ويمشي
فبالتالي الاربعين بالميه اللي كانت متاحه
من اول لان الظروف اللي صارت خلني اضيف لك
اليوم الصعوبه نسبه السائقين السعوديين ما
يصلون سته سبعه بالمئه اوف نعم لانه عندهم
الفرص الاخرى اكثر بكثير احنا نصل الى
6000 ريال
ابدا لكن خليني بعطيك انا يمكن سبب يفسر
زين
الفنيين احسن حنا الحمد لله كانت بالبدايه
سبعه بالمئه ثمانيه بالمئه اليوم وصلنا
الى 25 30% لانه صار عندنا خريجين وصلنا
نستقطبهم ونستثمر فيهم الحقيقه ودي اختم
ابو فيصل بسؤال يعني يشغل بال
كل سكان مدينه الرياض وهذا سؤال ملح متكرر
متزايد متصاعد اسالك خبير الشركه
متى تعتقد مشكله الزحام ستنتهي في الرياض
او انه لن تنتهي هذا قدرنا يجب ان نتصالح
معه والله يا اخي شوف انت لازم تعرف انك
تعيش في عاصمه ضخمه وعاصمه يعني تسابق
الزمن في النمو وزي ما قلت لك انا كنت
اقرا في احصائيه الرياض قبل 90 سنه 1930
كانت خمسه
اليوم تتكلم عن تسعه مليون او ثمانيه
بوينت
تتكلم عن تصاعد في عشرين سنه الاخيره
الدبل من حوالي الف كيلو متر مربع الى
الفين وترى اليوم حسب ما سمعنا ونشوف
الرياض مقدمه الى مرحله تزيد من تسعه تصير
بين 15 و20 مليون هذا المربع الناس انه
اذا كذا
بالضبط فكيف تصير الحياه في الرياض او
خلينا نقول معيشتها مقبوله وكيف تنسجم مع
جوده الحياه اذا كان عندك ازدحام وكان
عندك الانبعاثات الكربونيه وكذا اتنقل على
فكره بصعوبه
لن يكون الا ان اليوم انطلاقه المشروع في
الرياض في تسابق اكبر بكثير من النمو على
اساس انك توفر استخدامات الاراضي انك كل
المشاريع الجديده اليوم تبدا تبني فيها
محطاتك وتبدا تربطها بوسائل النقل السريعه
ترى الفكره هذه الحين نمر فيه اليوم اليوم
مرت فيه دبي اللي يضرب فيها مثلا احيانا
دبي انا اذكرها في 2004 وصلت المرحله انه
عندهم كل شيء جميل جميل جميل الا ازمه
التنقل كنا نجلس 50 دقيقه ننتقل في مسافه
عشره كيلو بالضبط اللي نعيش اليوم في
الرياض وقفوا هيئه النقل والمواصلات جابوا
خمسه سي او واحد يمسك الطرق يصلح فيها
ويوسع ويكبر واحد يمسك القطارات واحد يمسك
الحافلات واحد يمسك وسائل النقل الاخرى
بعد خمس سنوات اذا تتذكر التاريخ المشهور
تسعه تسعه 2009 انطلق البترو انطلقت
الحافلات انعكست الايه وصارت بالمدينه دبي
صار
انت اللي كنت تحتاج 50 دقيقه تروح تقطعها
صار اعتقد سائق التاكسي يحتريك في المول
50 دقيقه يجي دوره يلقى له راكب فحنا
اليوم انا اتاكد انه بطالما عندنا هذه
الرؤيه فيها المشاريع الضخمه وفيها كل يوم
مشروع انا اعتقد انه اليوم احنا مشكلتنا
في السباق كبير بس تكون اسسنا ان شاء الله
واخذنا
والهيئه الملكيه اليوم مثلا على مثل
الرياض والهيئات الاخرى تحذفها اليوم فقط
صراع وسباق مع الزمن
لضخ المزيد من فتح الطرق ربط المحاور
الجديده والمراكز الجديده
واطلاق المزيد من الحافلات ترى احنا اليوم
نحتاج يمكن خمسه اضعاف اللي نحتاجه عشان
نغطي المدينه بس ايش
خطوه بدايه بدايه نتاكد من اتجاهات الطلب
حجم الطلب ونجاح التجربه اللي انا واثق
فيها ان شاء الله
ولعلنا ان شاء الله نلتقي فيما بعد ونقول
واو اثرنا نتوقع الامر اكثر صعوبه انا
اعتقد انه ان شاء الله بيكون افضل واكثر
سلاسه
والنقل حيبقى هو المحور الاساسي والركيزه
لاي تطور مدينه متوسعه والحياه فيها هم
يقولون دائما يعني في المثل الشعبي ما بطش
الا من كبره
ابطى علينا
ان شاء الله الله يعينكم لتلبيه هذا
التوقعات والتفوق عليها باذن الله بالعكس
حنا في اسعد الساعات وباختم في الاخير
اقول شكرا لهذه الرياض انا اقولها يمكن
هذه الوحيده اللي بتجرها اتكلم فيها
بالنيابه عن الهيئه الملكيه لاني انا لا
امثلهم لكن اقول حقيقه اهل الرياض في
صبرهم على هذا المشروع والفتره اللي
عاشوها هذا الصبر المحبين الصبر المتعشمين
صبر الطامحين
حقيقه شيء يعني يشار له بالبنان انه كيف
الناس يحبهم لعاصمتهم وانها تتطور وتتمدن
كيف يعني ما شاء الله عديناه ترى انا
عدينا الكثير ما بقى للقليل شكرا لك الله
يسلمك شكرا لكم شكرا قصير في اعداد وانتاج
الحلقه عبد الرحمن العطاس وياسر خلف
الكاميرات في تسجيل الصوت عبد العزيز
المزي وفي التحرير محمد الديني في الهندسه
الصوتيه محمد الحسن وفي الاشراف على
الانتاج رزان هذا بودكاست سقراط احد
منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]